petit
à chaque saison la césure à ses airs de
fête
réseau ça rassure c'est bien leur dépôt
est à chaque saison la césure à ses airs
de fête à la raison se rassure c'est
bien leur des poètes
on passe de jean leloup à grand corps
malade
moi j'aime beaucoup grand corps malade
on l'a dit depuis deux trois chronos
mais est ce que c'est bon ça
moi j'aime je suis un peu oui parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de sang 5e et au
moins ya trouvé une manière de se
réinventer en fait parce que l'islam
c'est difficile de changer la formule
c'est très récitatifs sur toi que cette
voix grave que grand corps malade mais
cet album là il nous restera ça y était
de l'album concept en fait il a demandé
il veut que son album de poésie il
réunit les plus grands auteurs
il leur donnait une seule consigne vous
devez écrire un texte autour de cette
phrase il ne nous restera sa donc
demandé à charles à ce niveau à hubert
félix thiéfaine est à fred pellerin
parce que faire écouter un extrait mais
la grande curiosité en france et renault
parce que renault là-bas le retour de
renault en france est attendu comme le
retour de christophe je suis revenons
vous le même ce que - et renault a dit
oui à cette invitation de grand corps
malade il a composé une chanson qui
donne quelque chose d'un peu étrange
parce que sa voix est pas où se mettre
sa forme ça s'insulte à batterie on
écoute
alors
sur mon amour
ah ah
bonjour
le prisme couleurs jusqu'à ce que
laurent je brille
et dans le bruit des arrivants par
milliers mer air et enfin des familles
sans scrupules sur la propriété
voyez la rivière et sa source en fait
c'est la belle surprise fred pellerin
qui chante sur cet incident à dc salonen
et qu'il chante réflexe sur une musique
électro ne jamais entendu ça parce que
d'habitude on entendu préféré avec des
violons taishan l'invité qui exactement
je ressens exactement le 3 ou 4 fois
mais moi ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est
ça c'est fred pellerin sur une musique
électro composé par babic seul français
avec cette espèce de monter encore une
fois spectaculaire il nous restera ça en
plus une transe qui a des connotations
de bilan d'héritage raconte l'histoire
du monde
c'est bon c'est comme la trame sonore du
film bruits viennent avec tom cruise et
youtube sont donc composé par des
français m83 c'était vraiment à voir
donc son premier chef quoi écouter
écouter la auld a réagi le grand-père
les minimes en substance cent trente
mille exemplaires de l'album mes amours
mes années des succès de paul daraîche
interprétait qu avec ses copains et
collègues ses amis comme patrick normand
et la récidive avec un peu la même
concept est-ce que ça sent le réchauffé
sur indices qui s'intitule laisse moi te
dire même concept avec des artistes un
peu plus jeunes et des idoles de
jeunesse moi j'ai beaucoup aimé avec
david thibeault avec un participant de
voice en france le québécois j'ai
beaucoup aimé cette chanson mon métier
c'est la scène on en extrait de
l'enfance j'ai compris au bassin
je suis comme un poisson dans l'eau
s'ils veulent me reste or aucune gêne
c'est que je suis bien dans ma peau
j'aime tout
donc avec avec les plus jeunes je trouve
que ça fonctionne avec kevin parent avec
david thibeault avec patrice michaud
aussi mais par contre avec ses idoles de
jeunesse évite les appelle comme ça par
exemple adamo petula clark que j'ai
moins aimer qui on veut entendre aussi
paul daraîche nous a fait danser un peu
parce que tout le québec simona vous
dansiez pétrole à québec
neuf cent soixante mille personnes
apparemment déjà vu danser ouais ouais
on va reparler de sables d'olonne
j'avais pris la vie' d'olonne qui a
tourné le clip d'adèle dunham donnant
moins connaître comme en ville quand
même scène se passe à l'intérieur le
plus beau vol vosges
oui oui on va le voir mais c'est là
c'est la sortie c'est l'événement
musique aujourd'hui d'avoir le retour
d'adam ses traits bleus chanteuse qui va
encore des millions d'albums son album
sort le 20 novembre ça s'intitule twenty
five et elle a demandé à xavier dolan
c'est elle qui l'a approché de réalisé
le vidéoclip pour cette chanson et ce
qui est drôle c'est que j'entendais
dolan ce matin j'ai gravé le matin
d'hier j'étais vraiment étonné qu'elle
me contacte parce que généreuse qu'elle
évolue dans un autre monde
c'est donc dire que xavier dolan évolue
lui aussi dans la même sphère cadel est
bonne bravo se quitte là dessus ballon
décalé perfectionner votre bout vaut pas
de danse jsr pour une prochaine émission
personnes
ça